hello everyone if you've seen my
previous video or if you follow the news
you already know that program ananda has
won his third grandmaster norm and we
already seen one game from this
tournament but i decided to show another
one this is a game from round eight and
this is basically his last game as a non
Grandmaster chess player so it's a game
he played against 17-year old Italian
Grandmaster Luca Maroni and it's also a
very nice game and it's a special nice
since it's played against a grandmaster
so before we check it out I do have a
nice photo challenge for you in this
video who are the two gentlemen here in
this photo and for some extra points
which one of them is celebrating his
50th birthday so best of luck to
everyone now let's check out the game
Prague has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to b5 the real opus and
here we have 90 G to e7 the co-ceo
defense something not not seen that
often in high levels in high level
chests and it's also a very nice
opportunity for Prague to really you
know take advantage of this of this
peculiar idea it's not a peculiar idea
it's just that it's if you're not used
to it yes okay maybe black can take
advantage of this but you know in books
or if you ever you know studied the
reuleaux pass a theory you're not gonna
you're not gonna find any advice to
actually play this move but okay he is a
grandmaster so he can play it we have c3
g6 d4 he kept her son d4 seek after some
d4 and Bishop to g7 b5 attacking the
knight on c6 and now Knight to e5
immediately is perfectly fine but first
a six prabhu goes back with the brush of
Bishop to e2 and now Knight to e5 we
have Knight captures the Bishop captures
and Knight to c3 here look a place d6
here okay maybe if you are very new to
chess and maybe capturing the knight
here does seem like a good idea to you
but after B captures on c3 and black
would simply have to to
many weaknesses regarding the dark
squares for example if black decides the
castle here simply brushed up to h6
attacking the rook rook moves and after
Queen before there is no defense against
Queen to g7 checkmate black can't stop
it but black would lose so much material
here that it would be pretty much like
resigning so just putting that out there
so instead d6 we have castles c5 now and
the c5 would be a very nice
bone structure here for black if
probably started to do nothing about
this then b4 b5 could come before so
Praga captures a ton poisson we have d
captors on c6 b captors on c6 and now
Bishop to h6 and now you can see that
even though black has a dark square
bishop a white managed to play better to
h6 and prevent the black from castling
and here we have another move that well
it seemed pretty awkward to me d5 now if
you've ever read any chess book about
chess principles or something like this
if you have if if a player stopped your
King from castling you will always see
the advice don't open the center but
it's very interesting to me that d5 is
actually the strongest move recommended
by the engine Luca Marrone II plays it
and you know in the in this modern era
of engines you know it's obviously ok to
break principles but ok Queen to d3
we'd have Bishop to e6 and now f4
attacking the bishop Queen to b6 this
comes with check you have to move the
King King h1 and D captures on e4 Knight
captures on e4 and now first and in
between move to develop the rook rook to
d8 Queen to a3 and now the bishop has to
move the bishop doesn't have all that
many good squares you can go to g7
Bishop is guarding it you can't go to f6
Knight is guarding it you can't go to d6
both knife and Queen are guarding it so
Bishop could DeForest played and now
comes the Bishop to g5 and this is a
beautiful move by pregnant under the
threat of course is the immediate Queen
captures on e7
this would be checkmate and it's not all
that easy to prevent this for example
you can't move the night because you
lose the rope here if you play rock here
then it's again it's not all that easy
Bishop to f6 simply wins the game pretty
much immediately if you capture a bunch
of captures then Knight captures and you
lose the rook and even if you don't
capture it after Bishop to f6 even if
you move the rook rook to g8 then first
rook a to d1 so now the threat is
capturing the bishop on d4 and after
Queen moves then Bishop captures rook
captures and now Knight to f6 again
pinning forking the king and the rook on
GA King moves and now after a couple of
captures now the knight cannot capture
as it's pinned from the Queen on a3 so
atropine capture screen captures and
white would be up a whole rook so it's
not all that easy to defend this
position here c5 is played we have nice
to f6 check and now Bishop captures on
f6 you have to give up the bishop pair
and you no longer have any grip over the
dark squares you cannot you know just
disregard this play King here as the
bishop to h6 would be checkmate now so
you do have to capture it Bishop
captures on f6 we have Bishop captures
on f6 and rope the g8 now rook 8d one
bringing the last rook into the attack
and again black doesn't really have have
all that much to do here rook captures
rook captures and knights to d5 now
hoping together Knight into the game
also attacking the bishop on f6 Bishop
moves and now King to f8 breaking the
pin we have Bishop to f3 now with a
double attack on the night and queen b5
now Bishop captures on d5 Bishop
captures and now Queen to e3
of course you cannot capture the bishop
if you capture at Queen 2 F 1 will be
checkmate
so Queen to b3 instead going for that
very nice each 7 square we have g5 now
first trying to open the G file we have
Bishop captures and now Queen to c6 now
with a very nice attack against the g2
pawn and maybe in the future black could
take advantage of the rook and under
semi open G file but it's not going to
happen Queen to e7 played by Prague oh
we have Kings to g7 and now
to e5 check f6 and now Queen captures on
d5 queen cap Queen to e7 check is also
playable but probably evaluates the
position very precisely and he sees that
Queen characters on d5 is simply
crushing so Queen captures we have rook
captures now a white this upper piece
black has the capture of the Bishop
Bishop capture pawn captures Bishop on
g5 and now we have rook captures on g5
with check this is the last move that
was played in the game hence the title
progress last move as a nun Grandmaster
and here Italian Grand Master Luke
Amarone
resigned the game what if you resign our
the king is in check the King has to
move after King moves you can simply
grab the rook and now it's five points
against three and such a king upon
endgame is always winning or most of the
times but here it's definitely winning
as what probably does have two extra
points
so after this rook captures and g5 Luca
Marrone resigned the game and prabhu
achieved his third grandmaster norm and
thus you know became a grandmaster so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and if you haven't checked by
any chance my previous video I will just
show it once more here is now the list
of the youngest brand masters in history
first is still servi-car king because he
became grandmaster at 12 years and 7
months then second is pregnant with 12
years and 10 months so two of them are
are the only two chess players to
achieve the rank of Grandmaster before
reaching age 13 then we have another
back abbulu Satoru from Uzbekistan para
Mario Negi from India and Magnus Carlsen
from Norway in fifth place with 13 years
and 4 months so yeah
that's those are the standings now and
we also have as I've shown in the
previous video a nice create a
congratulation as tweet from Viswanathan
Anand himself so yeah that's the game
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Danny McCullough for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
one of them will be
another gameplay by program this
tournament so we've had if you haven't
feel free to check it out thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video